[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
murat ist gerade fleißig mit
juni in der werkstatt hoffe ich
zumindest und ich bereite jetzt schon
mal das mittagessen vor heute gibt's
hähnchen cordon bleu mit kartoffeln und
gemüse und hinten cordon bleu das ist
wirklich ganz einfach herzustellen
cordon bleu ist einfach ein gefülltes
schnitzel mit schinken und mit käse
ich nehme jetzt hier puten schinken und
dann noch den käse von ghazi und zwar
den krawall schnittkäse er hat nämlich
eine ganz tolle schmelz eigenschaft ich
habe ich jetzt noch die
hähnchenbrustfilets und entweder könnt
ihr jetzt einfach die hähnchenbrust
nehmen einschneiden füllen und dann
panieren oder ihr macht so wie ich wir
werden die jetzt nämlich auffallen und
dafür muss ich sie erst einmal platz
drücken
jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder halbieren
aufschneiden also so eine art
schmetterlings schnitt und dann platt
klopfen oder einfach so direkt blatt
klopfen und dafür nimmt jetzt entweder
im fleischklopfer oder um auch dort
starb
[Musik]
wichtig ist beim umgang mit geflügel
immer dass ihr immer hände wäscht und
später auch alle utensilien richtig
schön sauber macht und jetzt habe ich
hier das fleisch würzen mit salz und
pfeffer und jedes schnitt liegt jetzt
bei mir auf einer folie das brauche ich
nämlich gleich zum aufrollen
[Musik]
dann nämlich wenn käse und den werde ich
jetzt einfach ganz fein hobeln damit ich
schöne käsescheiben habe habe ich noch
ein bisschen was offenes daher das
stimmt zu
[Musik]
und dann legt jetzt einfach eine
schichtkäse rein
[Musik]
dann drohten shingo da geht natürlich
einen richtig guten geschmack ihr könnt
auch alternativ passte man eben als er
den rinder schinken aber der schmeckt
halt sehr stark also der hat dann schon
seinen eigenen geschmack
deswegen würde ich jetzt da er den puten
schenken bevorzugen und dann einfach mit
der folie zusammen
vorsichtig auf rollen so dass die
füllung schön der mitte bleibt mir
weiter mit wickeln und am ende
verschließen so dass wirklich eine
schöne feste rolle entsteht
die werden dann später noch pariert und
dann raus gebacken aber vorher lasse ich
sie dann jetzt 30 minuten ungefähr im
kühlschrank ruhen damit sie einfach
schön ihre feste form bekommen
[Musik]
und die folie könnte immer schön zu
hilfe nehmen und das ganze ist und bis
jetzt und rücken damit wirklich eine
schöne kompakte rolle entsteht dann
einfach auf rollen die enden zusammen 12
und dann leg ich es hier irgend so eine
schale und kann es noch mal im
kühlschrank für etwa 30 minuten kühl so
bleibt die formschönen fest und dann ist
ganz wichtig dass alle utensilien hier
richtig schön sauber gemacht werden
wegen dem hähnchenfleisch alles schön
sauber machen die kinder ordentlich
waschen und geht später mit der bahn
arbeite hier habe ich jetzt das fertig
gekühlte cordon bleu und ich habe in der
zwischenzeit auch schon kleine
kartoffeln abgekocht kleine drillinge
kapsel abkühlen lassen und daneben auch
noch gefällt ich habe jetzt meine
pannier station und zwar habe ich hier
an der ersten station erst eine mail
dann meine eier da kommt noch salz
pfeffer und ein bisschen sahne rein
hier habe ich paniermehl und dann habe
ich noch hier nachos die werde ich jetzt
erst noch zerkleinern und die sorgen und
dafür dass das cordon bleu richtig schön
knusprig wird und das ist einfach
nochmal anderen geschmack bekommt ein
bisschen bekannt
[Musik]
und vermischen
das riecht schon richtig lecker ist
jetzt noch das ei vorbereiten
[Musik]
planerin
das nehme ich hier aus der folie heraus
taucher ist dann zuerst den nähe und
immer daran denken eine hand ist die
trockene hand um eine hand ist jener
fahren sonst habt ihr vor schwinger
panierte frau schwanger
[Musik]
jetzt geht's ans kritieren das
frittierfett habe ich bereits aufgesetzt
und auch schon erwärmt hier habe ich
jetzt noch an der pfanne mit etwas
butter für die kartoffeln die kann ich
ja schon mal rein geben
die kann ich schon ein bissel anbraten
den dampf schränken will noch besser das
ganz langsam ein bisschen eine schöne
kruste bekommen und bei uns gibt es dann
noch bisschen brokkoli dazu und brokkoli
den gar nicht immer nur ganz kurz in
wasser mit bisschen natron und salz
durch das natrium bekommt nämlich der
brokkoli nicht diesen braunen schweiger
also damit eine frau unserem bleibt
schön grün und die habe ich jetzt bereit
meine frittierfett aufgesetzt und ich
hab das einfach hier mit dem core
prozessor gemacht denn da kann ich
einfach auf stufe 5 und das ist einfach
die vorstufe und das fett wird dann
nicht überhitzt und dann einfach ganz
vorsichtig ins heiße frittierfett legen
und von allen seiten schön auspacken und
bei geflügel ist ganz wichtig dass es
wirklich komplett durch gebacken wird
[Musik]
acht minuten später kleines stück hole
ich jetzt schon raus ist größere lasse
ich noch ganz kurz als er bei hähnchen
lieber auch eine minute länger träumen
lassen als zu kurz hier kann ich jetzt
die kartoffel immer zwischendurch
schwenken und die werde ich jetzt
einfach nur noch salzen und pfeffern und
später mit petersilie bestreuen
die habe ich jetzt ja das natron wasser
mit sein da kommt ihr doch der brokkoli
mit rein populistischen und den mag ich
echt ganz gerne relativ bissfest also
wirklich nur ganz kurz los ihren lauf
nehmen name auch noch was schönes grünes
mit dabei
[Musik]
und beim frittieren ist immer ganz
wichtig nicht so viele sachen ins heiße
fett legen denn das fett kühlt dann ganz
schnell runter und dann schäumt ist und
mir ist echt einmal passiert und ich
wusste damals nicht warum das ganze
führt über geschäumt ist echt super
gefährlich deswegen lieber immer wenige
dinge rein legen und dann nacheinander
frittieren
vor allem weil es hat eben auch große
und kalte stücke sind
[Musik]
von ihrer liebt ja brokkoli da gebe ich
jetzt einfach noch ein stück butter
reihen salz und pfeffer und vom markt
gegen alle analysen
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
ein bisschen semmelbrösel übrig die
vermisse ich jetzt einfach miteinander
und wachse dann so aus wersau als
wegschmeißen war schön dass genutzt
regis noch
session als spitzel zum anrichten schon
aufschneiden oder jeder schneidet selber
opfer keller
denn diese spirale sieht nicht schön aus
[Musik]
jetzt darf der moral zum probieren
kommen lieber murat kam probieren ja
cordon bleu okay vom huhn mit puten
schränken problem zu erklären
normalerweise ist der korb am limit mit
kalb oder mit schweinen alles klar und
eigentlich ist es ja durch schneider so
eine tasche rein aber ich hab's hand
gerollt
der court unglück in jeder ja hier schon
gestern ich glaube ich hab's nicht
erfunden
okay das war eigentlich jeder außer
neben vegane risch der wagen ja aber
vielleicht mag dann im brokkoli
kartoffeln okay ich habe nur die
petersilie salz und pfeffer habe ich
schon
das habe ich ihm versprochen mit peter
ich kann heute nicht sein das ist doch
immer ehrlich aber die die panade
spanien ja so schmeckt partie frittiert
ja und ich habe übrigens bis alles
fertig waren lag ich einfach alle im
backofen da bleiben sie zum einen schön
warm und ziehen auch noch mal ein
bisschen also bei hähnchen wirklich
immer gut aufpassen dass hier wirklich
selber durch sind die panade da ist in
latsch schuss drin sind laut schuster
kleinert macht was bitte macht will das
merkt sowie der geschmack ist einfach
noch mehr kartoffeln natürlich immer in
der heißen pfanne gemacht hier herrschen
gekocht und dann in butter in der alten
fahne mit den kartoffeln schmecken alles
wirklich nur aus der eisenbahn erst dann
bekommen sie eine tolle kruste ich
glaube da mehrere negative werden dass
auch gleich mögen sie mir liegt der
brokkoli erlebt fleisch sanierer auch
viele aus der wüste kerner nur ganz kurz
ich hoffe ich als ins wasser
ja ganz liest man vocal salzen und nicht
verkochen hammer dadurch weiter ist man
muss nur fotografieren
denn auch weiter essen ich habe welche
für die fotos aufgehoben also der
schmeckt gut
diese soße oder gar nicht gar nicht mehr
kurz überlegt mache ich da nie niemals
man neigt wegen dem käse oder das ist
übrigens eine deutsche eigenart dass man
alles mitzumachen tränkt er trinken so
sind ja teile soße wir haben cool zur
laufenden käse das angebot nochmals
schafkäse und putten schenken
den gab es schon so geräusch hat sollte
auf jeden fall murat schmeckt ja dann
habe ich meine mission erfüllt
[Musik]
und das ist glaube ich noch nie gegeben
koenigs rausschneiden weil es denn mal
mit jungs in denen es noch mal einen
dauerstreit
da hat er noch gesagt ich sage so
gemacht dass wir damit war ganz toll
hast du ganz toll gemacht hat ich liebe
dich hallo ich freue mich aufs nächste
mal und ich habe ich bin erkältet ich
habe fertig gekocht ich und meine kinder
also ist eigentlich für unsere kinder
aber auch ganz toll
danke ich muss aber weiter so gingen zum
alex in die garage
[Musik]